photos and videos out of a Canadian High
School are going viral as they show a
male teacher wearing what appears to be
a large prosthetic breasts in full view
of young students when someone is being
absurd like that
and it's a lot of other things besides
absurd it's perverse and abusive and
everything else but it's also absurd and
the appropriate response to absurdity is
to laugh at it we should actually teach
our kids to laugh at it if I had a kid
in school
teacher comes in like that
um first I would be proud of my my child
for laughing
if they pointed and laughed and said
that's the dumbest thing I've ever seen
I would be so I would be proud of them I
take them out for ice cream afterwards
and say yes that's exactly the way to
respond but the next thing I'd be doing
as the parent is I'd be marching down to
the school
and saying get that pervert out of the
classroom okay no you are not going to
have a teacher acting out their sex
fetish in front of my my child that's
not going to happen